hey guys we're here with the official
Robin character breakdown from
NetherRealm now this did come from a
developer livestream so if you see
something weird remember that it's a
work in progress and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for all the latest injustice
two character reveals and breakdowns as
we like to usually let's kind of start
out with just his key normals in his
fighting stuff right so just right off
the bat I mean you'll notice he's
holding the sword he was just even the
way he walks is so cocky you know just
holding it up like that not even really
in a fight stance he just kind of like
hey look at this and so you know you'll
see just kind of like how flesh he is
you know right on the back you know he
doesn't just when he attacks you he you
know he's not just slashing he's like
rolling throwing the sword up in the air
and catching it and you know you know
he'll he'll like jump off his sword so
right some of those things just some of
those elements we really try to capture
this new set and it just doesn't work
out we don't need to show it all off yet
slow down let's go through some just
cool basic attacks that we have with him
um and then you know let's do special
mediums break him down right right so
just just kind of like you know Jim's
doing a couple like basic combos with
him you know so he's you know got some
things with the story that he's doing
good high-low combo right so you know
it's got some hinders that are low and
some of the things with some of those
low Enders and some of those other
things will be set up they obviously use
this setups for for some of the things
you'll see coming soon so you know but
you'll notice that's one of the big
things about them is just a range on
some of these normals you know you know
that this goes back to just because of
the nature of the sword and you know and
all that you just that's pretty pretty
terrific range on some buddies and Susan
so Rob Robin is interesting to me I play
a little bit she's very good at
controlling the mid rim yeah he is
really uh I'd also like to say this I'm
watching the stream chat if you do have
any questions specifically about Robin
you might see that we can actually
answer I'd love to
the other thing is somebody said oh my
oh my gosh damage all this stuff isn't
set yes yeah and so yeah that's a good
thing to bring up like you know I think
we're at the point right now where you
know I don't think you can really look
at damage um you know things are
changing things can be in flux so it's
probably not something to really this
game is still a work in progress right
right not put it in a box yet folks
there might be some sound cues that are
missing and maybe it could crash you
never know that's true it happens in a
long time it's called development yeah
we're still development so keep that in
mind as you watch the stream um so let's
just break down two special moves okay
so yeah right on the back um you know
we've got this this this week we call it
a source pin at least I do I'm just
really really good wake up attack you
know just kind of really quick really
just emphasizes the flashiness of his
character in general it's just very
useful you know overall and then of
course it can be burned here so there's
a pretty high high juggle too so you
could do a lot off that so that's like
kind of like one of the key moves that
he has is called swordsman
okay well that thing you could meet her
bring that yeah he gave me to bring that
and that's good for like it's a really
good like when you're on the ground wake
up awesome yeah awesome totally a couple
questions real quick and I saw from the
stream can Robin remove his hood via
gear ooh good well we are gonna find out
we'll find out soon enough
yeah another question that we took when
we talked about gear and they all have
their sort of accessory items yet Robins
is indeed sway ask historian yes yes
unless a new sword yep as you progress
leveling up and getting
we have a couple of the multiple foucha
literature um okay what else does you
have here Nick okay so one of the other
things that he has is he's not this move
called assassin strike where it's
essentially a full-screen move where he
just can kid he could get into it pretty
quickly and and you know when he runs
into you just because I got does that
like running slash sword slash sure um
so it's it's um it's pretty far word you
know please basically full screen you
see it coming did you see it coming but
but like you know you can use it in
multiple ways I mean it can be used as
Anders it can also you can also have
trick your opponents my stop right yeah
give you cancel out of it you can't oh
like yeah you can cancel out of it but
yet so it's um it's kind of one of those
ones I guess I would compare to katanas
a run possibly visit sure how can you
meet her oh there it is wait here area
so yeah just kind of shows like how yeah
he's he's not just gonna slash you this
and stab you if that's or it's just a
fool with him and then animove meter
burning it once he does that kick still
kind of puts him back in that mid-range
as well he does where Damien likes to be
he has a lot of really long reaching
sword stabs and help him control it for
sure yeah uh no let's go into his bird
iraq okay so yeah the bird Arang you
know is a really interesting projectile
so here's here it is so it's really it's
kind of like a smart gadget device that
you know kind of homes in a little bit
to some degree it's jumped um I've
played against uh sixteen bits and if
it's tricky like you got to watch when
you jump you got to watch it's very
tricky right you're right and that's a
pretty good example in the saloon you
jump up like basically what it'll do is
a little loop around and then at the
point where it's done looping it'll
basically track the last position you're
at so it's not like full-on homing like
oh I'll always adjust my position but
wherever is at the point where it's
about to cross the loop that's wherever
your character whatever the position is
as where is gonna go alright and it is
two hands neither burn which
let's see that be around us I'm dry so
it's got this meter burn here so I've
got these these bombs that come out top
you know as she like lost the guy with
it you like do other things until you
were scatter stalls around back - yeah
yeah yeah and so that'll hit low to six
as well so all right and then if he's
got his uh kickin thing would we call
that
well that's called swoop this okay so
he's got this move here right so he's
got this dive kick kind of moved which
kind of which is cool because it's got
like different ranges on it's like you
know got a little short range and long
range of stuff like that and traditional
dive kicks you actually do in the air
you do in the air this one is gonna be
only on the ground you know it's useful
you can like you should go jump over
projectiles it hits overhead but then he
gets on either side you - and at this
point is slightly event it's a pretty
pretty big does it have a meter burn hey
Doug this is my favorite class is my ah
you're getting good today have to ask
you - yes thank you Oh Scutaro gets put
display real quick forget people asking
him stream on the game - oh alright
practice options see it - you [ __ ]
log button that am I going down around
up up up up stuff down up stop go all
right okay cool right okay there we go
awesome okay so he also has a meter burn
on that and that can go from different
distances right he can go different
distances you can do like a short
version and you know somebody seasons
like oh let me do something about that
and then um does he have any other
special attacks just normal specials
that you
you did the run we did the run well you
did get the airflow okay yeah so he has
this this well I guess it's called come
on when it's called actually it's called
a sword spinner same move as the short
clip with your feet but you see me cry
it's the same Oh
so yes I guess I would be an air-source
yep so it's just kind of like an air
overhead just like a super flashy um you
know air overhead attack that's just
like a using the sword so it's got like
pretty good range on it and of course
yeah that one's got a meter bird version
too so Lepanto would you wait for me to
ask for it next time thank you can let's
just go over the his character kick
apart
okay yeah so so you know Damien's got
this interesting power I guess I could
kind of compare it to maybe what green
arrow did and injustice one so it's got
like he's got this gadget that has like
three it's kind of like three different
gadget functions and so you can put it
down like this so let's just hit the
gimmick button and it comes out and it
is there and you can see the meter
draining and this this one is the
version where he can teleport to it so
it's like he can put this thing down at
any point and then essentially teleport
directly to it so I mean you can use it
in many ways like you could you know put
it down you know save it for later start
a combo um you could you know in just
situations where you wanted to be now
say if you could teleport back to it so
it can be used like that and I could be
thrown at different distances different
distances yeah don't fall down behind
ponent teleport behind him right there
are two other versions of the two other
versions okay so you know the the one we
just saw was the version where you can
teleport to it and then so then you've
got the the other one just the red
version which is just a just you know
straight-up bomb you know so it hits low
it's one of the few attacks radiation
hits low in and and so that will just
like I launched the guy so it's a pretty
quick just just normal standard bomb
attack and then this one's kind of
interesting this this bluish
looking one so what you can do is place
it behind the victim and call it back at
a point in time and it will always hit
behind them so I mean you could there a
lot of setup up potential for that too
so you can I know somebody's jump in or
somebody's t-shirt they always have to
be thinking about where that version
that battering is so they can't get
caught by cool may I try now to show my
combo and see how many times it takes
first I'd like to ask the stream how
many times you think it'll take Tyler
before he actually nails the combo
I'm going with at least five minimum oh
hi when he showed it to me yesterday he
asked me the exact same question and he
hit it the first time so you never know
how many tries are you going with Nick
oh this time I would say probably about
three three times where he's gonna hit
another seven 16 12 five five seven four
four four million yeah that formalistic
130 one person's head one okay so the
stream one person has faith in you I've
told you what the stream covers here we
go
there's one does that go that's how we
count vehicles there's two and that
wasn't it
that you were looking prom again our
next 300 was a winner before night Nick
right with four huh here's why I missed
it
oh the TV was lagging of course oh right
no yeah I was I was pushing down forward
to not down back to Oh which does that
does that
sure good I just did it yep sure all
right well everybody that guess for your
winners you're gonna get prizes
that's Jessica Kim just uh as a lot we
do though after after you go away Oh
we'll have a giveaway from our good
friends at DC here today we're gonna
talk about that after I leave if we
don't leave yet
yeah more things to show for instance
Superman who wants to service
[Music]
swagger yeah exciting first why does yes
with us
a couple people on stream thought my
combo was cool really good um Nick do
you want to try and do super swagman
combo I know you showed us some stuff
earlier ah probably no no whatever I did
earlier I guess you know just couple
things we can just describe it to you as
we get done this this and I look nothing
like what happens how about you what
again okay no he's not alright so moving
on let's go on to some other different
version four versions of him yes that's
gonna do this
no don't no that's not what you want to
do you wanna go to AI yep yeah a little
bit
yep whoo so we got some new gear put on
and some a couple moves we were tied up
look at this is a sweet red laughs is
awesome yeah yeah this is cool well Nick
and I actually last night put put these
costumes together these gear sets
together and we wanted kind of like a
dark scary looking clear assassin one
hey yo Nick that was great um yes I
think that was time yeah that's right
that's good um yeah so this guy we did a
cool you know looking red assassin II
Nightwing and so we'll kind of show off
some of the gear moves that he has this
one's called line in the sand which is a
little bit different than I've ever seen
a move that I've ever seen su and so
what he does is he draws that line right
there
he'll fade out over time but you know
basically if the other character crosses
that line they're gonna take damage and
blues meter okay so you can kind of see
it now I mean it's doing decent amount
of damage right there so yeah they're
gonna lose damage and meter it's pretty
if you cross 350 brushy cross this line
I hate you must do it so but if Damien
crosses the line then it just goes away
and can't
to redo it so when you reset it up so
it's kind of cool like where you know
you might do a combo you might end it
with a line in the sand and just found
like force the guy to stay behind and
are you doing your back three just now
it says cost you twenty percent yes
absolutely or whatever that was good so
you know that one's pretty cool he also
has in this one we've set up a thing of
the low smart bird right uh right okay
so like we saw it you know what is
default mousex uh he had the normal
battering some are battering but this
one is the low version okay so you know
swoop in low you have to jump over it
and it does have a special meter burn
where you had throws three three pieces
of it essentially it explodes into three
pieces and travels for over the birdurer
yeah so it's kind of annoying - oh wow
no the hits three times it's fairly like
definitely want that it's pretty awesome
again to reiterate damage still the
balance process of all I mean is always
a moving car definitely something you
can't really look at right now I think
so there we go
I split show them my let's put together
the next one real quick and also I
really like the sword - oh yeah look at
the appreciate you're talking about well
so this one has more of a curve ball I'm
trying to it's got a cool little symbol
in the middle over curved blade like
I've seen some of the gear like there's
new hilt sushi blade yeah
like things are so many unique things
that you can liner to stock our I don't
got a better than my gosh well let's
let's do that just for a sec can you go
the move lata no okay what's up I just
wanted to show that the move list is
updated that that little purple right
well show you what abilities you have a
mocked up so then if you're like oh I
just got this new ability which one was
it
yeah what's highlighted there if the
purple yeah it's the purple one correct
and it slaps you in the face so we got
another color to show you which I think
everything's pretty cool and will answer
a question oh right after this
commercial
no look hey got a hood wearing wearing
blue
so you just gave it away Nick just going
in and uh place on hand all right
so this version we've added to the other
two others again like we spent in last
week we're not showing you every single
gear boom not all of them there's some
more stuff that Robin has it's very
exciting that we'll have to show how
exciting is that on a scale of like one
two super exciting how exciting to them
super exciting yeah I love super
exciting so so we just kind of a fun
color for y'all to look at of course
without that is wearing his towel now
and then we gave him a new version of
the swoop right right right
oops two points so you know a lot of
Damien's moves um you know he'll always
kind of end up on the other side but but
this one he teleports and and you know
so he'll still stay on that one side and
then you know I can set up for personal
other things and so it's changing
actually the meter yeah it's only yeah
it's only changing the meter per version
so right there's there's just that okay
and this one also his character power he
can use in the year so it's gonna throw
it out for sunjai yeah right okay so um
yeah so this gear move you can use set
up the the Batarang and then at some
point you can like use it out of the air
so you know there's just different
options you know for that and then he
has another one which I won't guess that
we'll talk about no we will not wait I
mean people on Twitter so they love
seeing the character but maybe leave
some stuff to be surprised by and there
definitely will be so I don't know what
you're even talking about super excite
about it so that ladies and gentlemen is
Robin in a nutshell
into that she'll we hope checking to do
more questions real quick for Nick
supportive heads off
[Music]
nope nope everybody's just saying see
you later that's not Nick please leave
Nick get back to work make we're tired
of you me why is he still there huh okay
they're meaner they're just kiddin Manor
all right though
anyway that is Nick Nicastro thank you
so much for coming by
thanks I mean that's awesome that is
Robin uh now we're going to get Steven
here to do that we need to do some magic
of film and show you a sweet trailer
that we released last week